hey what's up guys i'm pewdiepie and i'm
here at Gamescom 2016 joined by Lucy
James how's it going it's good I played
a game called and lit all nightmares
yeah you've not heard this well no no I
got like the email tease yep and it
turns out it's probably one of the
coolest things I've seen at Gamescom mr.
Ella bite hacer Studios who had never
heard of until this point but they'd
worked on every little big planet games
thus far yeah me too yes all by year
share the credit Media Molecule so this
game is like a weird there's a lot of
that influence in there the way their
character moves and the way the
mechanics work so you get this little
character named 6 she's like a look like
a sexy kind of in that it's the same
number yeah no it's not about our
galactic ax and so the story is this
thing called the more appears it's like
a lighthouse above ground but below it's
like this weird complex is like an
upside-down iceberg but the stuff within
it and people are naturally attracted to
it for some reason they didn't want to
be inside it she wakes up inside it and
needs to get out it's really really
strange and like the the actual game is
a platformer that feels quite similar to
stop like limbo and inside so idea i was
watching the footage that you managed to
get and yeah it doesn't want me lot of
limbo a little bit like the way that six
moves is also reminiscent of yelling
yeah but not as adorable yeah and also
like like we said littlebigplanet the
kind of just it's not the jumps on as
flowy but i kind of like the movement
and the feel of it it's quite like
Pilate kind of running and like you grab
so that's the main way you interact with
the world you've grabbed stuff and move
around so what kind of environments are
inside this like weird on the ground the
environments are supposed to be quite
diverse you start off in a kitchen type
area and you start get through this is
really large ugly looking chef is bad he
looks like the [ __ ] code from men in
black oh it does in his human form so
like you have to like it Vince
yeah exactly kingpin you gotta sneak
through this kitchen and he's around and
if he hears you he'll chase you down and
you've gotta try and get away from him
climb up and get out of there the whole
point I spoke to developers after is and
what they're trying to do is create
these worlds that are interesting and
quite unsettling and they're doing it
from like a child's perspective so the
thing that they said was a child doesn't
understand subtleties in life too much a
thing is either good or bad yeah i think
is eva big or small it's not like medium
or there's no like intricacies great an
extreme yeah everything's in extremes
and that's reflected in the world so
you're very small everything around here
is very big which is why you're like you
feel almost like you're a micro machine
in this massive world like you feel like
honey i shrunk the kids type and
character and that that's what makes it
interesting running and the other thing
to do is they're building the
environments to be quite baffling and
confusing because kids don't understand
things around them and they said there
might be some symbolism in those
environments that perhaps the child
might not understand but an adult would
also they have environments that are
designed to be weird without any sort of
symbolism or meaning just to be weird
yes because kids sometimes see things
and it's just like what is that I don't
understand it one bit okay it's just
weird to me one of these was like this
room where you land on a briefcase and
it's just full of hundreds and hundreds
of shoes I mean that can become that can
be really MacArthur I mean from the
butcher it's yeah like is it a man
eating pig butcher yeah what is it yeah
it's like it feels a lot like inside and
that was you know it's a fairly recent
game which is why I'm pulling that as a
reference point but atmospheric very
like slow pacing in terms of platforming
that kind of stuff it's got a vibe to it
which I'm really interested in and it's
come out of nowhere which is the thing
that excites me most about yeah so it
doesn't seem like bandai namco as usual
no this is interesting because this is
like the first game that they're the
European arm of Bandai Namco is both
publishing and mocking so this is kind
of like there
first step in realizing the Bandai
Namco's entertainment part of it they
want all their territories to start
looking into games finding you know
unique little gems and trying to push
them up and out there tarsier Studios is
a European div which is why discovered
by Namco Bandai Europe and they've
arranged this kind of like a publishing
agreement but like I definitely feel
like it's one to watch out for if you
like stuff like cool quirky platformers
with an atmosphere and like it's kind of
tension to it and it's got a bit of
stealth in there as well some puzzle
mechanics we've got you know cleaning in
there to look forward to I'm excited
about I'm really looking forward to
seeing more about it all right then come
more from this year's games can't make
sure you stay tuned of course to
gamespot com